[موسيقى]
سبعه وعشر دقائق بالتمامي والكمال اهلا
وسهلا بكم في برنامج النقاش يمكنكم
كالعاده ان تتفاعلون عما يقولون ضيوف
البرنامج على صفحتنا على فيسبوك وعلى صفحه
البرنامج على تويتر مثل ما تشاهدون على
الشاشه في النقاش سنحاول ان نعرف ما الذي
تريده ايران كيف يمكن لبلد يتخبط في ازمه
داخليه بسبب احتجاجات في الشارع منذ مقتل
ناس امينه ان يستمر في انتاج اليوراني من
المخصب بنسبه 60% وفي شن ضرب الاكراد فوق
الاراضي العراقيه كيف تدير السلطات في
طيران هذه الاستراتيجيه في كل الاتجاهات
ماذا عن دبلوماسيه الرهائن الاجانب في
ايران الى اي حد تسعى ايران الى امتلاك
السلاح النووي كي تستخدمه في الطاعات مع
الغرب مثل ما تفعل موسكو في حربها مع
اوكرانيا سعيد بان اناقش الموضوع مع هناك
في الاستوديو هشام الغنام وهو اكاديمي
وكبير في العلاقات الدوليه سعيد بان تكون
معي من خيرا هدى رؤوف ويا استاذه العلوم
السياسيه وباحثه في الشئون الايرانيه
وسعيد بان يكون معنا من بيروت على حسن وهو
كاتب مختص بشان الايراني اهلا وسهلا بكم
ابدى مع ضيفي من بيروت يعني الاسئله كثيره
هنا خاصه في الغرب يعني ايران منذ فتره
طويله ومنذ مقتل هذه الشابه ويتخبط في
مواجهه احتجاجات في كل المدن الايرانيه
ومع ذلك نسمع بانها تواصل انتاج الايراني
المخصب توجه ضربات تقريبا يوميا ضد مواقع
كرديه داخل الاراضي العراقيه يعني ما هو
هذا السر الايراني
اسمع في اسمح لي بدايه ان اصحح نقطه مهمه
وهي عباره الازمه الايرانيه في الحقيقه في
بدايه الاحداث التي بدات منذ شهرين ونصف
تقريبا كنا امام بدايه ازمه مان لكن اليوم
ما بعد مضيء شهرين ونصف يمكن ان نقول اننا
امام اضطرابات نعم هناك اضطرابات متنقله
داخل ايران لكن لا تعيش ازمه داخليه في
الوقت الراهن بسبب وذلك بسبب ان الزخم
الشعبي موجود في المظاهرات او اعمال الشغب
الموجوده هي ليست بكبيره جدا من حيث العدد
في المقابل نحن لدينا عدد من المحطات التي
اظهر فيها الحضور الشعبي الموالي للدوله
الايرانيه الحاليه مثل تشيع بعض الشهداء
متى يوم الطالب عفوا يوم الطالب او بعض
المحطات الاخرى بالتالي
من الاضطرابات المتنقله داخل ايران امام
اضيف الى ذلك ان الحياه في ايران اليوم
مستمره المؤسسات الدوله تعمل بشكل كامل
مؤسسات الخاصه الشركات الاسواق كلها تعمل
لذلك نحن لا نستطيع ان نقول انها تواجه
ازمه فعليه نعم هناك بالضبط
بالتاكيد هناك اعمال شغب وبعض الاعمال
الارهابيه لكنها لا ترتقي بالنسبه لايمان
الكبيره ان نقول انها ازمه هذه في البدايه
وبالتالي امام هذا المشهد بهذا الشكل
يمكننا ان نقول ان ايوان مستمر بتقديم همم
الانجازات التي تريدها مستمره ببرامجها
التي وضعتها على المستوى الاقتصادي على
المستوى السياسي على مستوى التقني وغير
ذلك نحن مثلا كشف النقاب منذ فتره قليله
عن موضوع اكبر تلسكوب او عن موضوع ااه
القمر او الصاروخ صوتي او او او او
نفسنا امام دوله ايله للسقوط او للانهيار
لنقل انها امام ازمه وبالتالي كيف هذه كيف
هذه الازدواجيه بين كل هذه الازمات وبين
انها تريد ان تخصب اليورانيوم بالنسبه ل
60% طيب اعتركه هدى رؤوف تتفاعل معك حول
هذا الموضوع لان نحن على الفيديوهات
هذا لا يدل على انها مجرد اضطرابات تفضلي
تفضلي هدى
مساء الخير طبعا انا يعني شايفه ان ما
يحدث في ايران هي ازمه وازمه مستمره منذ
ثلاثه شهور هذه الاحتجاجات هي نعم في
سنوات الاخيره ايران شهاده احتجاجات
مختلفه لاسباب كثيره على خلفيه اقتصاديه
على الخلفيات كثيره لكنها كانت سرعان ما
يقوم مؤسسات الامنيه في ايران في اخماد
هذه الاحتجاجات لكن الاحتجاجات التي
اندلعت على خلفيه مقتل مهسابيني استاذ
مستمر حتى هذه اللحظه لمده ثلاثه اشهر
اثرت على الوضع في ايران المؤسسات الامنيه
او بنتكلم عن قوات الشرطه اللي بتهرب من
امام المحتجين تم نقل كثير من المراكز
بعيدا عن المدن لان بيتم ادراهم النيران
فيها هناك فعلا ازمه بيواجهها النظام بشان
هذه الاحتجاجات سواء من ناحيه اا اطاله
امادها او من ناحيه حتى تطوير للمحتاجين
لادوات جديده بنجد ان تعطيل الانترنت في
ايران ادى الى يعني من خلال السلطات
الايرانيه طبعا عشان يوقف هذه الاحتجاجات
احيانا بيسمي الطاقه تعطيل الانترنت ده
قصر سلبا على التجاره الالكترونيه وعلى
كثير من الشركات التي اغلقت والتي كانت
بتقوم بالاساس على استخدام الانترنت في
التجاره وبالتالي حتى اا اغلاق الانترنت
عشان تعطيل المحتاجين اثر على الاقتصاد
الايراني المتدهور بالاساس وبالتالي لا
ايران بتعاني من ازمه خاصه بيتماس مع هذه
الاحتجاجات همم اندلعت هذه المظاهرات في
كثير من المدن ومحافظات الاقليات المهمشه
اساسا وبالتالي الازمه ليست اصبحت ازمه
همم حقوق وحريات للمراه ولكن حتى دخل
اقليات على الخط ثلث الخط من البلوش حتى
هذه اللحظه هو بالتالي همم ايضا تريد ان
تصدر الازمه خارجيا وبالتالي هناك ضرب
لمناطق كرديه داخل ايران وخارج ايران في
شمال كردستان العراق ثاني لا النظام
الايراني بيواجه ازمه ال- اا احتجاجات هذه
ايضا وجدت صداها في تفاعل عالمي مستمر حتى
هذه اللحظه سواء على المستوى الشعبي او
المستوى غير الرسمي وغير الرسمي
رسم الدول الاوروبيه اللي كانت بتقف
احيانا او بتاخذ موقف مريم مع ايران بدا
تتخذ موقف متعلق على خلفيه هذه
الاحتجاجات فرض عقوبات على شخصيات من
الحرس الثوري ومؤسسات امنيه وبالتالي لا
هناك ازمه حقيقيه تواجه النظام في الداخل
لكن هل ستؤدي الاسقاط النظام او عدم
اسقاطه هذا السؤال لا يستطيع احد ان يجيب
عليه غير الايام طبعا يعني
طيب
»
اذا اذا تسمح فقط اريد ان اعقب على كلام
الاستاذه هدى بان
هناك معلومه يجب ان ندركها بخصوص موضوع
الشرطه ان الشرطه هي الوحيده التي تتصدى
المتظاهرين وان الشرطه همم ليس لها صلاحيه
بحسب القانون انت تستخدم السلاح والرصاص
الحي لذلك يتستخدم الهوايات فقط وسلاح
البيل بول المعروف ولذلك عندما عندما
في صفوف المتظاهرين
القتل القتل الموجودين من من صفوف قوات
الشرطه اكبر بكثير هناك تحقيقات تجري في
هذا الخصوص انا لا اريد هنا ان ابرئ
الدوله الايرانيه بالكامل ويقول انها لا
ليس هناك اي عمليه مال ان التحقيقات لا
تزال جاريه لكن حقيقه حسب القانون الشرطه
لا تستطيع ان تعمل
في هذه
الامه
لم يسمح لها بالدخول لم يسمح لها هذه
القوات بقمن الاحتجاجات هذه النقطه المهمه
قوات الشرطه محمد اسمح لي بس اسمح لي ليست
قوات الشرطه فقط التي تواجه المحتاجين
ولكن برنسيس هناك
رامي السعيد ببعض ميل الشياكه وبعض
المسلحين منى خارج ايران هناك بعض المسرح
قريش المسلحين
طيب طيب ساعود اليكم ساعود اليكم هذه نكته
هذه نكته دوله دوله دوله مثلا دوله مثل
الايمان لديها 85 مليون نسمه من يستطيع ان
يساعدها من الخارج
لكي يساعدها من الخارج
يتحدث بعد هشام لم يتحدث بعد
في بيروت
نعم طيب مساله تصدير الازمات من قبل ايران
الفكره موجوده
مساء الخير بدايته اه بعض الكلام
بعض الكلام الذي قيل عن اعتقد انه يعني
كانت اتحدث عن عن السويد والعنرويج ودول
اسكندنافيه
كيفيه التعامل مع المتظاهرين والحقيقه انت
بامكانك ان تدعي ان هناك غفرا على منس
ناصر خارجيه ترجع الى هناك مغامرات ارهاب
لكن هذا لا يغير من الواقع على الارض شيئا
في ازمه حقيقيه داخل ايران في انهيار
الاقتصاد الايراني اقتصاد المقاومه هذه
هذه الكذبه الكبرى هذه الشعب ايراني يعاني
منها يوميا فيها في تدهور داخل خيران غير
مسبوق والمظاهرات هذه المستمره همم حاليا
مختلفه عن السابق لان الطبق الوسطى وطبقه
الدنيا مشاركه فيها هذا لم يحدث سابقا
استمرارها حتى الان رغم القمع الشديد يعني
اعطينا اشارات جديده هذا اولا ثانيا يعني
بالمقابل يعني عشان اكون متوازن في
الترحيل هذا لا يعني طبعا النظام سيسقط
غدا يعني لا احد يقول بذلك كلاشك ان
الافكار الاساسيه النظام قد تغير بنيه
النظام قد تتغير اذا استمرت هذه المظاهرات
بهذا الشكل الانعودين على سؤالك
تصديرها للخارج نعمل راينا تصريحات ضد دول
الخليج ضد المملكه مثلا على تصريحات ايضا
همم ضد قوى عالميه اخرى لابد من تصدير هذه
الازمه الخارج قطعا لان في في صعوبه في
التعامل مع الداخل الايراني وايضا المعارض
الايرانيه الفعاله في الخارج في ثوره عامه
لا شك في ايران نراه بوادرها الان وفي
ازمه حقيقيه هذه الازمه غالبا ستستمر لكن
معه القمع المستمر قد تخف وطاتها في
المستقبل البعيد وليس القريب لكن هل هذا
سيغير شكل النظام الحالي لا هذا يحتاج الى
وقت لكن سيغير ايضا سياساته اتجاه الموضوع
يعني يهم النظام الايراني البقاء في
السلطه هذا يعني هذا هدف اساسي ده انا
اتصور الحقيقه انه سيحاول
يعني ايجاد مفاهمات اقليميه
حتى يخفف
وطات اليوم اقرا تصريحات لهم نريد ان
نحضرها بعلاقات جيده يعني هدات الان وتيره
التصعيد الخارجي يريد علاقه جديده مع دول
الجوار والاخص مع المملكه طبعا كله يرد
علاقات جديده الكل يريد تهديه في المنطقه
لكن اذا لم يتغير النظام الحقيقي في نظرته
للجيران العرب
وايضا يعني انت الان تمول هذه همم هذه
الميليشيات في ارجاء المنطقه من اموال
الشعب الايراني ومن الاقتصاد من الاقتصاد
الايراني وتدعي انك اقتصاد ما يسمى اقتصاد
المقاومه هذا الان يعني قائم وانه صلب
وانه قوي وان الشعب الايراني سعيد انه لا
توجد مشاكل في ايران وان يعني الضفه
المقابله في الخليج العربي همم نفيه يعني
تشابه في النموذج لا هذا غير صحيح طبعا لا
لا يوجد اي شبه بين النموذج اللي نحن في
دول الخليج وبين النجاح الاقتصاديه وبين
هذا يحدث الان في انقسام في النخبه
الايرانيه همم في افكار تخرج من هنا ومن
هناك وفي رغبه في تعديل بعض الافكار
الرئيسيه الرئيسيه في النظام نفسه لكن هل
هذا سيد هل هذا سيغير النظام يعني مباشره
لان اتصور نحتاج الى وقت حتى ربما ربما
الموت يحل بعض الامور تذهب بعض القيادات
الكبرى في ايران ياتي جيل يعني يحاول ان
يكون اكثر منطقيه واكثر عقلانيه وان يرى
يعني الضيف يقول ان يعني همم دوله فعلا
دوله دوله كبرى فيها فيها همم فيها شعب
يعني
فيها شعب محب للحياه هذا الشعب يخرج
الشوارع الان في اغتصابات في السجون في
قتلها في الشوارع في قتل اطفال حتى
الايرانيين في الخارج المفروض الممثلون
ايران نراه يعني
في امتحان الان وفي جرعه على هذا النظام
كره القدم
موجوده في السابق لان هذا النظام يعني همم
شرس
قمعي يعني وعند قدره على الانتقام فهذه
الجراه يتراها بالايرانيين في الخارج
الحقيقه اكيد انها انعكاس لما يحدث في
الداخل على بدات الانتقادات حتى في الداخل
الايراني وحتى من وجوه معروفه في الداخل
الايراني هل بدات ايضا المراجعات لدى
السلطه في ايران
نعم نعم
اوكي اوكي اوكي اسمح لي فقط انا وعقب على
ضيفك في الاستديو انا لا اقول ان هي هي
السواد اساسا هناك اختلاف بنيه
وليست ليست دوله ليست دوله همم تسلب
الاطفال من همم حضن اهاليهم كما تفعل
السويد وليست دوله ايضا همم
بالحب بالسجن لمده 15 سنه
قامت بتغريدها همم
هي دوله تستوعب لا لا لا لا
في الشارع
اسمع لا هذا ما تفعله السعوديه فالحقيقه
عندما تخسر الابطال
الخارجي
كما تستند اليها الان لكن الحقيقه الحقيقه
ان هناك ان هناك ان هناك دوله ودوله
مؤسسات لا يوجد دوله في المنطقه كلها يجري
فيها انتخابات منذ 40 سنه الى الان كما
يجري في ايران الشعب الايراني الكبير هو
حاضر في صناعه قرابه هذا ما يجب ان يفهمه
كل المحللين وكل من يعني
بشان الايراني لا يجب ان همم
الى بعض التقارير الاعلاميه التي لا تعكس
الواقع حقيقه لان الشعب الايراني
هناك هل هناك مؤشر لتغيير ما في النظام
هذه الاحداث هذه الاضطبابات التي حصلت
وقلت في البدايه انها كانت بدايه ازمه
ولكنها تحولت الى اضطرابات لانها تحولت
الى اعمال شغب فقط القتل في اصفهان وفي
شيواز وفي خوزستان والهجوم على منازل
الناس وقتل وضرب المقدسات هذه ليست اعمال
احتجاجات وليست تظاهرات هذه اعمال شغب وكل
دول العالم بما فيها فرنسا وفق القانون
تواجه هذه الاحتجاجات بالقوه القهريه هذا
الموضوع غير النقاش لا يمكن امام امام
هل هناك اما بالنسبه لسؤالك الكريم
بالنسبه لسؤالك هل هناك مؤشر الى تغيير
هذه النظام وهذا الدوله حقيقه لا يوجد اي
مؤشر لهذا الموضوع لا على مستوى السياسي
ولا بما ااه ذكره ضيفه همم اذا حصل موت
للقيادات الموجوده
لان هناك قانون هناك دستور وهناك اناس
يعملون ليل نهار لحفظ هذه الدوله وهناك
كثر لا دعك دعك من مقوله ان هناك قوات
امنيه لا تشارك وقوات كادت هذا لو كان
موجودا لبان
ظهر لكن عندما همم يتم قتل ناس اغبياء همم
في همم دور العباده او في الاسواق وكذا
ويخرج الاف مؤلفه من الناس لتشيعهم هذا
المؤشر الذي يجب ان يجعله الناس
الخاصه مع حضرتك بالنسبه للنقطه الخاصه
بانظام الايراني هو دوله مؤسسات ومؤسسات
منتخب على مدار 40 عام يعني هذا الكلام
الذي قاله ضيفك الكريم انا حابه اقول حاجه
ان ان يعني حرث النظام الايراني على ان
يقوم بجميع الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه ليس
منطقه اا ديمقراطيه او اعطاء الحريه
للمواطنين بلل على عكس كان الهدف منه هو
استكمال الصوره الخاصه به همم يعطي النظام
شرعيه بمعنى ان النظام كان بالنسبه له مهم
جدا انه يعمل انتخابات لكل او لمعظم
المحافظات المنتخب عنده علشان يعطي شرعيه
ده ثواني بس اكمل معلش عشان يقعدني شرعيه
او يقول ان ان المواطنين راضين عن النظام
لكن بعد كده اللي حصل طبعا لو احنا شوفنا
الانتخابات مجلس
البرلمان الايراني الانتخابات السابقه
التي تم السبعات كثير من الاصلاحين فيها
في يسيطر عليه بشكل كامل المتشددين حتى في
الانتخابات ال- ال- الرئاسيه همم كان في
احجام حتى من قبل المواطنين عن همم
المشاركه في الانتخابات لان الناس كانت
عارفه ان كثير من الاصلاحين او ما يسموا
بالمعتدلين او حتى
التيارتي تم تقيده وبالتالي تم استبعاد
الكثيرون منه همم من اجل بتاعه الفرصه ليه
التيار المتشدد وبالاخص ابراهيم رئيس
وبالتالي هنا حينما نتكلم عن انتخابات
فانت هتتكلم عن انتخابات شكليه في النهايه
وصلنا الى نقطه ان جميع مؤسسات الايرانيه
حتى المنتخبه او المعينه يسيطر عليها او
هي سياد المتشددين والمرتبطين بشكل اساسي
بالحرس الثوري اما اذا كان النظام عليها
ان يراجع نفسه لابد ان يراجع نفسه لان هذه
الاحتجاجات مثل ما قلت لحضرتك في البدايه
هي مختلفه عن سابقتها سواء حتى من حيث
اطاله امدها من حيث المطالب من حيث
التضامن العالمي من حيث النداء والمثل
لفرنسا واوروبا وبريطانيا والمانيا بدات
انها بدات تبعد عن النهج اللين والمرن في
التعامل مع ايران الى الى فرد عقبات الى
امر اخر مهم جدا هو من يقوم من يقوم
بالمظاهرات الان معظمهم معظمهم ليس من من
المراه فقط ولكن عندك ايضا ما يسمى بيجيء
له الشباب الذي ولد بعد عام 2000 هؤلاء
الشباب طبعا من يجد من يقتله من زملائهم
في ال- ال- المظاهرات هؤلاء الشباب لديهم
طوق للحريه
هم شباب الانترنت وبالتالي هم يريدوا
مزيدا الحريه ومن هنا هذه هي معضله النظام
كثير من التقارير بتتكلم عن ان كثير من
همم ممن يقوم بتحقيق مع المتظاهرين
بتتحدثوا عن ان الشباب بيتكلموا باللغه
غريبه ومختلفه ومغايره لما يعتدوا عليه في
السابق وبالتالي اعتقد ان من صالح
الايراني انه يعيد النظر ان يسمح بهامش من
الحريات لان في النهايه همم كون ان ان ان
يتم تقييد حريه المؤمن ليس مواطنين فقط
ولكن المراه والاقليات انت تتسع عندك
قائمه المهمشين والمطهدين في الداخل
الايراني
رد على ماذا بس كنت اريد اتفقنا على لحظه
لا يستحق الرد عليه يعني موضوع مثلا ان في
عمليه ديمقراطيه تحدث ايران لان نحن نعلم
ان هذا فساده عمليه سياسيه موجوده كان هذا
يعني ناديمقراطيه
مع كامل الاحترام والتقدير الحقيقه هذا
كلام يعني اعتقد انه هراء يعني ولا يقف
على دليل الان المشكله النظام ليس لديه لا
منجز همم سياسي ولا منجز اقتصادي ولا اي
منجز في معناها في ازمه وجوديه لهذا
النظام حاليا وهو الان انا اعتقد انه في
اضع في حالاته الان ناتي للعامل الدولي
انا اعتقد الان الاوروبيين دخولهم على
الخط بسبب ما يحدث في اوكرانيا
اللي تذهب من ايران الى روسيا الان فرنسا
شعره والخطر الايراني عندما كانت المملكه
وغير المملكه يحذر من هذا الخطر الايراني
كانت هذه الدول تقلل من هذا الخطا الان
اختلف الموضوع رات هذه الدول ماذا يمكن ان
تفعل ايران في مساندتها لروسيا في غزوها
ليوكرانيا الامر الاخر يعتقد انه مهم
النظام لا بد يحل الموضوع لابد من طريقه
يعني حاله الانكار هذه ومحاوله المقارنه
بفرنسا والسويد والسعوديه والامارات ممكن
تتهم انت عندك قائمه طويله ممكن تضعها في
اقامه الاتيام لكن هذا لن يحل الموضوع في
ازمه والشعب الايراني سينفجر من الغضب وفي
يعني في انهيار اقتصادي وفي فقط ونظام لم
يحقق شيئا لان انت تدعي انك تمثل محور
الممانعه والمقاومه في المنطقه اسرائيل
تقوم بصفعك يوميا في سوريا وانت لا ترد
عليها انت لا الان رديته على اسرائيل لان
جحت اقتصاديا لان تحقق اي شيء ممكن ان
الشعب الايراني يرى فائده في هذا التمويل
لهذا من الاشيات خارج جراء طب ايران تدعي
الان ايضا ان فيه يعني نووي سيختمها حتى
هذا ترى مشكوك فيه يعني من يعلم بدويات
العلوم السياسيه غير الكلام الصحفي
والاعلامي الاعلام من السلاح النووي ليس
بهذه البساطه يعني هو ممكن يعطيك برستيج
معين يعطيك وضع عالمي معين ممكن يحمي
النظام نفسه من الانهيار لكنه لن غير
المعادله في المنطقه يعني ايران لن تستخدم
السلاح النووي ضد اسرائيل مثلا لن تستخدمه
في اماكن اخرى في العالم في الاقليم او
خارج الاقليم لانها تعلمنا رده الفعل
ستكون قاسيه جدا وستم تدمير هذا النظام عن
بكره ابيه الان الذي الذي انا اتصور انه
سيحدث ستستمر هذه المظاهرات سيستمر القمع
سيتم الادعاء ان فيه يعني همم في همم خلاف
بين الاجيال ان فيه بعض الاقليات هنا تثور
تثور هنا او هناك بس في ايضا عامل
ديموغرافيا ضاغط على ايران مرور الوقت
معدل المواليد طبعا في شعوب الايرانيه لا
يوجد شعب الايراني في شعوب ايرانيه تحتها
هذه الدوله تحتها هذا النظام همم في
اقليات كبرى كبير معدل المواليدها اعلى من
الشعب الفارسي هذا ايضا عامل نظافه وتتعرض
يعني عندك ما يحدث في ما يحدث مع الاكراد
ما يحدث مع التركمان هذا كله سيستمر
وستضخم ستضاعف في الايام والشهور والسنوات
القادمه لنقل اذا العظام لم يحلها مع
جيراني ولم يحلها في المنطقه ويهدا من من
تهوره الاقليمي هذا كله سيرتد عليه وربما
نشهد نهايه النظام على يد النظام نفسه طيب
على حتى نتقدم لاننا دخلنا كثيرا كده حتى
نتقدم اريد رايك مثلا في مساله دبلوماسيه
الرهائن طبعا هذه الدبلوماسيه الجديده
خاصه
انك يعني تحجز اشخاص تتهممهم بانهم لهم
دور يلعبون دور في هذه الاحتجاجات
وتستخدمهم هل هذا يمكن
ان يساهم في اعطاء فكره مختلفه
على سؤالك هناك نقطه يجب التوقف عندها بغض
النظر عن هدف النظام من اقامه الانتخابات
لكن في النتيجه انه حصل على الشرعيه
الشعبيه
العمليه
الحقيقي
ومعنى الانتخابات لكن لكن ان يكون هناك
توجهات مختلفه او ان تزيد نسبه الارتفاع
او تخف نسبه الاختراع
هذه المشكله مختلف
هذا هو الشاعر
العظيم ان يقاتل الانتخابات
ولا يسمح لشعبه باجراء الانتخابات لكن
الحقيقه الحقيقه وهذا هو الغذاء الحقيقي
الذي يتدخل نحن في لبنان هنا نعلم من هو
السفير الذي يتدخل في كل كبير
تطبق اليك طيب طيب خلينا في دبلوماسيه يلا
انت تتحدث عن التدخل ايراني في لبنان انت
انت تتحدث عن تدخل ايراني
طبيعي وان الشعب اللبنانيه لا يعاني فانت
يعني خارج هذا العام
عفوا عفوا
الموضوع يلا خلينا في النقاشه
وضع طبيعي
طيب طيب خلونا فيران الحلقه
منذ 40 سنه استطاعت ان تحقق امكن
استراتيجيا لم يحققه احد رغم كل الحصار
والان هي تواجه الولايات المتحده وتواجه
الناس عبر تقويرها
في اماكن اخرى
للشعب العراقي
على الشعب الايراني
بالتاكيد اذا هو قناه التلفزيونيه تؤثر
بهذا الشكل اين العمق الاستراتيجي الى
صلابه المؤسسات اين الشعب الايراني انا
القائد الشعبيه التي لديه انا شخصيا انا
شخصيا
على التلفزيون
ان كثير من المعلومات نعم هذا هذا طبعا
هدى بما ان علاء لم يجبني الان دخلنا في
دبلوماسيه الرهان ما يثير يعني سخطا كبيرا
في الغرب حتى في فرنسا يعني اختطاف او
عمليه خطف لاشخاص يتهمون ويجنون ويتهمون
بانهم يحرضون على التظاهر في ايران
يعني لو احنا بنتكلم بشكل اساسي عن
الموضوع دبلوماسيه
الاجانب او الرهائن يعني منذ سنوات من قبل
الاحتجاجات وايران بتلعب بهذا الكارت كورق
الضغط في مواجهه الدول الاوروبيه دائما
حينما تريد ان تساوي فتبدا انها تتكلم عن
استراتيجيه تبادل او همم الرهائن او
اطلاقه عدد من الرهائن او المعتقلين في
سجونها وهم من مزدوجي الجنسيه وبالتالي
هذه احدى الاوراق البائسه اللي بتستخدمها
دائما ايران من اجل التفاوض او يعني تجد
شيء تساهم في مقابله مع امام يعني الغار
بس او الولايات المتحده او دول حتى
الاوروبيه لكن انا في نقطه بس حابه ارد
عليها على الاستاذ اذا كان بيتكلم عن فكره
النظام الايراني بقى له 40 سنه ومستمر رغم
الحصار هذا الكلام يعني همم في النهايه
هذه الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه من يدفع ثمنها
اين هي يعني اين حقوق المواطنين ال- ال-
الايرانيين اين الحقوق والحريات يعني
المستوى المعيشه وبالتالي انت بتتكلم عن
اقتصاد ما يسمى باقتصاد المقاومه
هي فكره انك تحويل موال ده بطول الوقت ليه
امور اخرى غير همم ده البيت او رفع مستوى
واحتياجات معيشه المواطنين الذين يطوفون
الى الحريه مستويات معيشه مرتفعه مثل من
الدول حواليهم في الخليج نحن نرى الطفره
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وحتى على مستوى
الحريات موجوده في الخليج الان لكن في
النهايه المجتمع الايراني بيحتاج الى مزيد
من الفقر وهمم
التضخم والبطاله وفي النهايه بيتم قتل
الناس على خلفيه همم هل ملتزمين بقواعد
ال- همم اللبس وفقا للنظام الايراني ام لو
بالتالي في مشكله همم فعلا لدى النظام
الايراني بيدفع ثمنها المحتاجين اللي
كانوا في 2017 و18 بيرفعوا شعارات مرتبطه
به لا سوريا ولا لبنان وبالتالي كان هم
شايفين ان الاولويه بتكون ليهم هم لتلبيه
احتياجاتهم لكن في النهايه مفهوم جدا طبعا
همم النظام الايراني بعد 79 افكاره اي ما
على ايه بالاساس وفكره التوسع طلعاتها ما
وراء الحدود وبالتالي ده بيدخلوا في ازمه
فعلا حقيقيه يعني فكره انه في انه يعني
كان في فتره من فترات نوع من النبذ
الاقليمي والنبذ الدولي يعني لكن ايران
ايران تتوق الى احياء الاتفاق النووي الان
من اجل ان تندمج في المجتمع الدولي تريد
ان تندمج لن تستطيع ان تندمج في دول وسط
وشرق اسيا ومنظمه شهر للتعاون والانف وهي
تفرض عليها العقوبات وبالتالي السياسه
الايرانيه الممتده منذ 40 عام همم لم تؤتي
س- بثمارها على النحو الذي يرفع مستويات
معيشه المواطن او يجعل ايران دوله طبيعيه
في وسط محيطها الاقليمي وبالتالي ده جزء
من او سبب الازمات التي يواجهها هذا
النظام ولا عليها بالاكل في فتره معين كنا
امام دول غربيه
وخاصه الولايات المتحده على استعداد
للدخول في مفاوضات مباشره مع طهران
والتواصل الى حل في المجال النووي يعني
وصلنا الى مرحله حتى وانا ط السؤال في
زياره بيضه على وزير الخارجيه السعودي
فيما يتعلق بالعلاقه حتى بين السعوديه
وايران كانت الامور جاهزه وجاءت هذه
المظاهرات وتغيرت الوجهه ولجات ايران من
جديد الى تخصيب الايراني مدخلنا في حق
اخرى كنا في مرحله واصبحنا فيما حسب رايك
لماذا هذه اولا اقتصاد المقاومه بمناسبه
بهذا الاموال تصرف خارج ايران حتى في
الارقام يعني في يعني منظومه قائمه على
التسجيل يعني وخداع الشعب الايراني اما
الان بالنسبه لسؤال الاتفاق النووي اعتقد
ان هو السؤال المفصل يعني تعتمد عليها
اشياء كثيره همم همم هل ايران ستسارع الى
القنبله النوويه ام ستقف عند العتب
النوويه في اكثر من حسبه انا اعتقد ايضا
السؤال يقع العاتق دول المنطقه ايضا دول
الخليج تحديدا ماذا ستفعل اليوم الذي
التالي بعد ما تحصل ايران على قنبتها مثلا
او اذا وقفت على في مرحله التشكك النووي
لفتره طويله لابد ان يكون هناك خطه لتعامل
مع هذا الامر انا اعتقد المصالح الاقليميه
وانا يعني هذا ليس سر يعني انا انا كنت من
من همم يعني يشجع هذه المصالح الاقليميه
في كامل بين كامل دول الحقيقي همم سواء
الاتراك مع الايرانيين كامل لكن همم الذي
يحدث الان من النظام الايراني عنده ازمه
داخليه هو لم يستطع التعامل معها حاول
بالقمع لم يستطع التعامل معها قد يلجا الى
الاسراء نحو القنبله النوويه او الاتفاق
النووي الخطين هذول ليسوا متعارضين على
فكره يعني هناك الان في جماعه دولي الجماع
دولي قوي ان لا تمتلك ايران قنبله باي شكل
هذا يا جماعه في اقوى حالاته الان ايران
تعلم هذا
فساحرس ايضا على اقفال اي اتفاق فيينا
ستتنازل الان مع هذه الازمه انا اتصورنا
ستنازل حتى تقفل الاتفاق النووي واذا لم
يحصل لها هذا ستسارع نحو مرحله تشقق
النووي يعتبر نوويه لكن تجربه سلاح نووي
مثلا
تجربه سلاح نووي قد تعرضه من المشاكل
الكبيره الى ضربه عسكريه تستهدف النظام
نفسه
خيارات صعبه الان لا بد ان نحسبها بدقه
لكن ايضا دول المنطقه لابد ان تجهز نفسها
ليس ناري التصعيد قد يحدث في اي لحظه قد
يحدث اشتعال في اي لحظه انا اعتقد ان الان
المنطقه في حاله جاهزيه لحرب لحرب اقليميه
الوضع غير مطمئن من كل الاطراف الحقيقيه
الايرانيه الان يشعرون ازمه اذا لم
يتعاملوا بحكمه بعقل اعنيه ويقوم على
الاقل اول اول اول اول هذه الحكمه
العقلانيه يتعاملوا بعقل مع شعب هيلبوا
مطالب شعبيه حدث ينعكس ايضا على وضعه
الاقليمي لابد ان تتقلص هذه الغرام في
المنطقه هذه الاموال اي تصرف على المرتزقه
خارجي ايران لابد ان تصرف على الشعب
الايراني لا ان تصرف على ابواقه مرتزقه
خارج ايراني نعتقد ان هذه ماساه يعيش
الشعب الايراني الان منذ 40 سنه لابد ان
تنتهي في شعب صاحب حضاره عريقه في معارضه
ايرانيه فعاله في متظاهرين شباب وشابات في
الشارع يقتلون الان بدم من بارد هذا كله
لابد ان ينتهي على حسن نحن في نقل نوعيه
في المنطقه ام نحن على ابواب ربما
ازمه اكبر مما نعيشه اليوم بين هذه الدول
ان ايران يعني تقريبا كانت
قريبه جدا من التوصل الى اتفاق مع القوى
الغربيه وكانت قريبه جدا من التعامل مع
وكانت تريد رفع العقوبات وبالتالي نرى
يوميا فرض عقوبات اضافيه على مسؤولين
ايرانيين
بانفاق الغربي الحقيقه هناك مجموعه نقاط
يجب ان ندركها ونعرفها فيما الدوله
الايرانيه اولا همم انها تاخذ القرار لدى
الدوله الايرانيه بالحصول على حققها
باستخدام السلم للطاقه النوويه ولكن دون
الاخلال بهذا الحق كما حصل بعد همم
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بحسب
المسؤولين الايوانين انها تلعب دورا غير
محايد بهذا الخصوص لكن هناك نقطه مهمه
هناك نقطه مهمه انا الحديث عن الذهاب
ايوان باتجاه الحصول على القنبله النووي
وكلام تنفيه ايوان نفيا قاطعا من ناحيه
الشرعيه الاسلاميه ومن ناحيه السياسيه
لانها تدرك ان الحصول على القنبله النوويه
ليس في صالحها ولا صالح المنطقه هي لا
تريد ذلك ما الفائده من الحصول على
القنبله النوويه في هذا في هذه المنظومه
القائمه اليوم
باكستان نعم نعم
هذا من هذا من باب الضغط في المفاوضات
بتستفيد
تستفيد منه من اجل الحصول على حقوقها
الغرب للاسف لليوم لا يعطي ايمان الحق
بالحصول على الطاقه النوويه السلميه من
عاجل تحسين واضحه الاقتصادي من اجل تحسين
وضعها تقني او غير ذلك هذه هي المشكله
الجوهريه وليست ان هناك ان امام تريد
الحصول على قنبله نوويه همم استخدام
الباكستان لديها قنبله نوويه ماذا تستطيع
ان تفعل بها ليس الامر بالحصول على
القنبله النوويه ولكن هل يمكن هل هل قنبله
النوويه تصنع غدا حقيقيا انا لا تستطيع
وضع الحقيقه في الوقت الراهن وبالتالي ليس
من مصلحه ايران ولا تريد ذلك ب- همم
الحصول على القنبله النوويه
باختصار شيء موضوع مؤقت هل هي تخلق راجعه
من نوع الاوكراني لو كان يمتلكون السلاح
النوويه لو لم يتخلوا عنه لما حدث الغزو
الروسي هذا اولا فالنظام يعلم ذلك يعلم ان
هذه القنبله على الاقل ستؤمن النظام داخل
الحدود لكن لا تعمل منه خارج حدود قد تست
فضا عنيفا عن النظام لكنه ايضا يريد هذا
الرجل عباره عن ان عن خيارين
نيه وقدرات
هو هو يريد النموذج مثل النموذج الفرنسي
بالتحديد هل فرنسا تستخدمها هو يريد حمايه
النظام بهذه القنبله ذلك لا نستبعد ابدا
عن يسرع نظام نحو القنبله اذا كانت هذا
خيره الوحيد اذا فشل الاتفاق ولم يحصل على
ما يرده من الاتفاق لكنه طبعا لن يقوم
باستخدامها ابدا ولا يتجرا على ذلك طيب
تفضل عليها
هذا هذا ما قصدته هذا ما قصدته بانها
الدوله الايرانيه لم تفهم بشكل صحيح نحن
نحن لسنا امام دوله اقليات في حكم في حكم
اكثر واكثر ايات الناس يعني مختلفين عن
النظام من حيث العرقيه او الطائفيه او غير
ذلك كلا لا لانه ليس ليس كذلك الحقيقه ان
الامام هي دوله دوله هذا الشعب الذي
انتخبها بغض النظر بغض النظر عن ان هناك
اعتراض نعم هناك اعتراضات نعم هناك ازمه
لكن هذه الازمه الاقتصاديه تحدث لكن لا
تتحدث عن ازمه الحاليه
السياسيه
[ضحك]
الحركات الانفصاليه التي طرحت
مشروعها في الاسابيع الماضيه واجهت سقطا
شعبيا حقيقه رفض لانه موضوع قوميه
الايرانيه والحدود بالنسبه للايرانيين
موضوع مهم جدا لا يتقبلون تقسيم ايمان لا
يتقبلون هناك
هذا احد مكونات الشعريه لدينا شعب عربي في
الاحوال
الشعب الايراني
القديمه
التي بنيت على هذه الارض وهذه المساحه
الشاسيه التي يسكنون عليها هذا ما يجب ان
نفهمه ثانيا بما ان ايمان لم تفهم حقيقه
ايمان لا تريد مرتزقه ولا تقبل ان تتعامل
مع مرتزقه وهذه اهانه لكل الذين يتحالفون
مع ايران اولا وليبان نفسها فبت- فهذا
الامر ايمان تبيد حلفاء نعم ايمان تبحث عن
انقستراتيجي كما تفعل كل دول الكبيره في
العالم الولايات المتحده لديها قواعد في
الخليج لديها قواعد في كل في كثير من دول
العالم بعيد الاف الكيلومترات عن حدودها
ايمان التي تواجه اداءا الصريحا من قبل
الولايات المتحده ومن بعد الدول الاخرى
ومن بينها الكيان الصهيوني من حقها ان همم
تبحث عن عمق استراتيجي يسمح لها بالدفاع
عن حدودها بعيدا عن الحدود الجغرافيه
الطبيعي
لكن هذا لم يحدث
اسمح لي اسمحلي اسمحلي اسمحلي
اسمعني اسمعني ايراني
ولكن ما حصل ان ايران تبحث ايران تبحث عن
الخلفاء
وعندما اتحدث عن الحلفاء يعني ان هناك
مصالح مشتركه هذا يعني ان هناك مصالح
مشترك يعني همم لا يمكن ان تتضارب مصالح
المنطقه السوريه
ازي حضرتك قلتها اه اه في جزئيه حضرتك بس
قلتها يعني حضرتك بتقول كلام يعني هو اا
كلام يعني يرتبط بمبادئ وحاجات جميله ولكن
لو جئنا نتكلم بس الواقع لا لا حضرتك
بتتكلم على مرتزق الارتباط ايران بمرتزقه
لا تتعامل مع مرتزقه من اسس فايلق زينبون
وفاطميون من الافغان الشيعه الافغان ومن
باكستان الايرانيين من زرع هذه الميليشيات
في سوريا وبيتم تسكين وترسيخ وتوطين هؤلاء
الميليشيات المسلحه في سوريا بدلا من طبعا
لتغيير تركيبه الديموغرافيه في سوريا
ايران هي ما تفعل ذلك ايران هي ما انت
تستعين ايضا طلاب المسلحين من الخارج
للتعامل
بين النقطه دي قطعتني في الاول اسمعي
اسمعي اسمعي لا لا حصل في
المظاهرات الموجوده حاليا لان بعض من
عناصر الامن واثرهم رفضوا التعامل مع
المواطنين الايرانيين مثلهم وبالتالي بيتم
الاستعانه البسيج بداخلها بعض الجنسيات
الغير ايرانيه من الخارج الايراني للتعامل
مع المواطنين الايرانيين فبالتالي ايران
بتتعامل مع مرتزقه اما تبرير حضرتك
للتعامل مع المرتزقه همم او ان ايران
بتتوسع في الخارج عشان العمق الاستراتيجي
لانها بتواجهها اسرائيل طبعا لا يكون
حمايه الامن القومي لاي دوله على حساب
محيطها الاقليمي او على حساب جيرانها او
على حساب شبك همم نسج تكوين علاقات وشركات
مع الفاعلين من دون الدوله او الحركات
اللي هي غير تحت الدوله الموجوده في داخل
الدول تتكلم على لبنان سوريا اليمن العراق
ان ايران تونس علاقات مع هذه الجماعات
وبالتالي بيعمل على تفكيك هذه المجتمعات
باستخدام الطائفيه من ناحيه اخرى بيعمل
على طالت امد الازمات لولا لا يعني لو
التدخل الايراني والروسي ما كانش موجود في
سوريا كانت الحرب الاهليه في سوريا انتهت
لم تكن لتستمر حتى هذه الاعمده وبالتالي
التدخل الايراني
ادى الى ازمات ادى الى ازمات المزيد من
الدول المنطقه الختام كان من القاهره
لاداء رؤوف استاذ العلوم السياسيه وباحثه
في الشهور الايرانيه اعيدكم بنقاش حول
مواضيع مختلفه
وايضا من بيروت على حسن وهو كاتب مختص
بشان الايراني شكرا لفريق البرنامج همسي
مريحه الجميع
[موسيقى]